[Musik]
Müll gigantische Mengen lagern in
Deutschland auf illegalen halten
monatelange Recherchen zeigen jetzt das
Ausmaß
bundesweit sind es 330 illegale
Müllhalden mindestens das haben deutsche
Behörden frontal bestätigt gleich sieben
davon liegen im Landkreis
Potsdam-Mittelmark
Leiter des dortigen Umweltamtes und für
die Sanierung der illegalen Müllhalden
verantwortlich Ralf buschalsky
der Schaden für altbensdorf oder auch
Sitz ist halt immens wir schätzen jetzt
hier bei dieser Deponie
je nach Preisentwicklung der
Entsorgungspreise drei bis vier
Millionen Euro wenn man sich vorstellt
dass hier 500 Menschen leben wenn man
das umrechnet pro Kopf sieht man
eigentlich welche Belastungen das ist
und dass das eigentlich nicht zu tragen
ist das ist das Dilemma insgesamt knapp
300.000 Tonnen Müll wurden in der Gegend
illegal entsorgt Hausmüll Klärschlamm
Elektroschrott oder auch Kunststoff
durch diese
illegale Abfallablagerungen sind
Schadstoffe freigesetzt und werden
laufend immer noch freigesetzt die halt
das Schutzgut Grundwasser belasten
verantwortlich ein Mann der als müllpate
von Brandenburg bekannt wurde
2013 wird er zu fünf Jahren Haft
verurteilt die Strafe hat er verbüßt
aber für den Schaden ist der bislang
nicht aufgekommen er will nicht zahlen
und verklagt sogar den Landkreis
weil er sich natürlich weigert diese
Kosten zu tragen er hat da
offensichtlich
nicht den Eindruck dass er dort halt
Schaden verursacht hat dass er Recht
gebrochen hat
Landkreise und Gemeinden stehen mit dem
Schaden alleine da der Täter in
Privatinsolvenz
dabei ist das Umweltrecht eigentlich
klar sagt umweltrechtler Thomas
schumerus
ja einen Umweltschaden verursacht der
muss ihn beseitigen und gegebenenfalls
für diese Beseitigung auch zahlen also
im Grundsatz muss der verursache zahlen
soweit die Theorie nur in der Praxis
kommen die Täter auf davon
anderer Ort ähnliches Problem
scharmbeck-hünxe im Münsterland
was auf den ersten Blick wie ein
harmloser Sandberg aussieht enthält in
Wirklichkeit hochbelasteten Giftmüll
mindestens 25.000 Tonnen giftige
ölpellets wurden erst mit Sand vermischt
und dann in dieser Ton Grube der Firma
nottenkämper vergraben
deren Anwalt sagt das Unternehmen habe
von all dem nichts gewusst
und wir sind
systematisch
langjährig und mit mit ganz hohen
Aufwand sind wir getäuscht worden von
jemandem ganz genau der tief im
Unternehmen integriert war ja der für
den Vertrieb zuständig war und ähm
die man dem man vertraut hat seit zehn
Jahren laufen zu diesem Fall Prozesse am
Landgericht Bochum gegen mehrere
Beteiligte des kriminellen müllnetzwerks
den Schaden aber will niemand Zahlen
einer der Angeklagten gab an er arbeite
nur in einem 450 Euro Job und sei zudem
arbeitsunfähig der Anwalt ist schon
grobenbetreibers nennt so etwas sich arm
rechnen
das sind Leute die verschieden ganz
bewusst ihr Vermögen bei einem der auch
hier Beschuldigten gegen den
nottenkämper zivilrechtlich vorgeht
wissen wir dass Immobilien
verschoben worden sind auf seine
Lebensgefährtin seine Lebensgefährtin
die als Sekretärin arbeitet die hatten
Haus in Garmisch-Partenkirchen mit einem
riesigen Anwesen wir hätten riesiges
Anwesen in Solingen dass ihr gehört ja
wo man sich fragt wo kommt das Geld her
im Dezember wurde einer der Angeklagten
zu einem Jahr und 11 Monaten auf
Bewährung verurteilt den Schaden jedoch
muss er bisher nicht sein
laut Gesetz muss dann der
Grundstückseigentümer einspringen und
was wenn auch der nicht zahlt
auch wenn der Betreiber der
abgrabungsverfüllung das nicht mehr
irgendwann zahlen könnte wird das ja
trotzdem fortgeführt werden nur wer dann
die Kosten übernimmt ist dann die Frage
aber letzten Endes wenn sich niemand
anderer als Verursacher heranziehen
lässt der die Kosten zu übernehmen hat
dann wird das wohl durch den Staat
getragen werden
von den Tätern ist oft nichts zu holen
und am Ende zahlt der Steuerzahler das
Problem ist seit Jahrzehnten bekannt die
Geschäfte mit den illegalen Müllhalden
gehen nach frontal Recherchen trotzdem
weiter bis heute
frontal hat Daten aller deutschen
Landkreise und landesumweltministerien
recherchiert die Auswertung zeigt das
Problem hat Struktur betrifft nicht nur
einzelne Kommunen oder Bundesländer
sondern die ganze Republik mindestens
330 illegale halten gibt es auf denen
derzeit noch Abfälle Lagern würde jede
Tonne illegaler Müll tatsächlich
entsorgt bedeutet das nach Berechnungen
von frontalkosten von mehr als 1,2
Milliarden Euro
während Kommunen und Kreise zusehen
müssen wie sie die umweltsauereien
beseitigen verdienen kriminelle damit
Millionen
Ingenieur Benjamin Schwan hat illegale
Deponien untersucht und weiß wie die
kriminelle Netzwerke arbeiten
also ich denke das gehört mit diesem
kriminellen Machenschaften definitiv
überfordert sind solche Vorhaben die
nach uns im missionsschutzgesetz
zugelassen sind müssen regelmäßig
kontrolliert werden aufgrund des
Personalmangels findet das natürlich
auch nicht statt so findet halt
kriminelle Energie immer einen Weg
Schwan fordert eine bessere
Zusammenarbeit der Behörden die könnte
die Bund Länder Arbeitsgemeinschaft
Abfall kurz Lager organisieren ein
Interview mit frontal gibt es nicht die
Begründung erstaunlich Mangel seiner
bisherigen Befassung des
Leitungsgremiums der Lager mit der
Thematik der illegalen Müllentsorgung
müssen wir Ihre Anfrage leider
zurückweisen
immer wieder werden Vorwürfe laut auch
Behörden würden wegschauen
Delitzsch eine Kleinstadt in Sachsen
mehrere Firmen haben hier über Jahre ein
Biomassekraftwerk Betrieben eigentlich
durfte nur Altholz verbrannt werden
übrig geblieben sind filteraschen und
Schlacken anfangs wurden sie noch
entsorgt später einfach auf dem Gelände
abgekippt
Bilder einer Bürgerinitiative belegen
das
spätestens seit dem Jahr 2014 war das
dem Landratsamt bekannt wie ein
Prüfbericht aus dem Jahr belegt
über die befestigte Freifläche
hinausgehend lagerten sehr große Mengen
ca 10.000 Tonnen an Asche und Schlacke
als Halde aufgetürmt auf einer nicht
genehmigten Fläche
dietmamid ist sich sicher die Asche und
schlackeberge sind illegaler Müll eine
Gefahr für Umwelt-
diese Schweinerei Bürger hier derart zu
belasten
indem man den Müllverbrennung hier
abgehalten wird über Jahre das muss auf
dem Amt auffallen das zuständige
Landratsamt Nordsachsen teilt auf
Nachfrage von frontal mit
der Behörde lag zu keinem Zeitpunkt ein
konkreter und begründeter Verdacht vor
dass nicht genehmigter Brennstoff im
Kraftwerk verbrannt wurde
erstaunlich in einem internen Dokument
eben dieses Amtes aus dem Jahr 2012 ist
von giftigen Stoffen die Rede Zitat
bezüglich der Überschreitung an Dioxinen
und Furanen soll hier in diesem
Schreiben nochmals unser Standpunkt
ausgeführt werden mögliche Ursachen für
die Überschreitung des
emissionsgrenzwertes kann unter anderem
ein nicht genehmigungskonformer
Brennstoffeinsatz sein
der giftmüllverdacht in Delitzsch
beschäftigt sogar den sächsischen
Landtag
ganz offensichtlich wurden dort eben
auch behandelte Hölzer und auch Abfälle
verbrannt das war auch bekannt denn auf
dem Gelände lagerten auch große Mengen
Müll auch die Bilder der
Bürgerinitiative aus 2016 zeigen das
Resultat bis heute lagern rund 21.000
Tonnen giftige Aschen und Schlacken auf
dem Gelände
die Aufsichtsbehörde sieht bis heute
keine Gefahr
staatsanwaltschaftliche Ermittlungen
wurden eingestellt
Umweltingenieur Benjamin Schwan erwartet
von den Behörden dass sie all ihre
Möglichkeiten ausschöpfen
das Problem wird meines Erachtens im
Moment nicht mit der notwendigen
Ernsthaftigkeit betrachtet allein schon
aus dem Grund dass solche Verfahren
einfach zu lange dauern und das
verhinderbare Emissionen einfach
passieren aufgrund von Langsamkeit
hunderte
illegale Mülldeponien
Täter die kaum zu fassen sind
und ein Milliardenschaden für den Staat